hello and welcome i'm james murphy from mCoding
and today we're going to be talking about the
def main if name main idiom in python and why
you should be using it in all of your scripts
first off not every file is a script by a
script i mean a file that you intend to run
not a library so something like this
that just defines a function that
you're supposed to import in another file
is not going to benefit from this idiom
most languages like c++ or java have a kind
of boilerplate setup that you need to write
even to write the most basic function java
is notorious for having its public static
void main string args as one of the first things
that a programmer sees before learning to use it
but in python it's seemingly a lot simpler
all you need to do is say print hello world
but what i hope to convince you of by the end
of this video is that you should really prefer
this def main if name main idiom over just writing
things out in a line okay really quickly if you're
not familiar what is this name variable if you
run the script from your terminal or elsewhere
you'll see that the name variable turns out to
be this double underscore main double underscore
but if you import the file
you see something different
in this case we see the double underscore name is
if name main package dot import me to print name
the difference in behavior allows you to check
whether the file is being run as a script or not
if you see dunder main then it's being run as
a script and if it's anything else then it's
being imported you could just stop there and put
all the statements that you want to execute when
this is run as a script into this if block
but i say you should go one step further and
define it as a main function okay so you
can check whether or not your code is
being run as a script or being imported
but why why would you want to do this
is it just a way to flex on programmers that
don't know the idiom or is there a reason for
actually doing this well yes of course there
are reasons for doing it let's go over them
the first and most important reason actually
has nothing to do with the language itself and
everything to do with how people use it yes you
can use if name main to check whether or not your
code is being run versus imported but this isn't
what it signals to the person reading your code
if name main is used to signal that
this file is a script and you can run it
if i look at a file and i don't see if name main
i assume that i cannot or should not try to run it
it makes me think it's supposed to be a
library or that it's only meant to be imported
nothing about the python language actually
enforces this but compare it to using an
underscore as a variable name if you see
an underscore in someone's code they're
basically saying i'm not going to use this
variable nothing stops them from using it
but if they do use it they're kind of breaking
an unspoken rule in the python community
underscore means i'm not going to use this
variable and if name main means this is a script
don't keep your reader guessing if this is
supposed to be an entry point to your program
just make it explicit many editors like pycharm
use this as a signal you can see the file on
the left has this green arrow which says run
hello but there's no green arrow on the right
that's because pycharm knows the signal if name
main means this is something that i want to run
no if name main means this is probably a library
you're not meant to just run it but why should
you extract main out into a function instead
of just leaving the contents in the if block
here's a script that just defines some function
and then uses it to compute something even if i
put this code inside a name guard everything
that i do here is still in the global scope
in particular this variable i is a global variable
even if i didn't really mean it to be that
suppose i define a function to compute some value
and then later on i use it here i'm just trying to
add up some evaluations of this function based off
of this list but i have accidentally made a typo
i use the variable i here but the
name of the loop variable was n
when i run the code instead of
getting an error for my typo
i silently get the wrong value this is one
of the worst kind of errors that you can have
and this is all just within the same file
imagine if this happened in a different file
if in another file or at the console i do an
import star of the bad script i now have a global
variable i that i didn't know about so if it was
this file that defined the compute val function
this file now has a global variable i and it's
even harder than in the last example to find this
typo also in the case where you didn't have an if
name main at all just importing the script will
actually run it that basically means that it's
impossible to test your code without side effects
also note that there are plenty of cases where
importing your code happens automatically
this script explicitly imports the useful class
from the bad script and then writes it to a
pickle file it's clear here that we're importing
the bad script because we explicitly wrote it
but in this script there's no mention of the
bad script all we're doing is unpickling some
object we don't even know where it came from and
yet when we run this code we see that we did in
fact import the bad script and run all of the code
that was in its body this is because pickle.load
automatically imported the bad script in order
to get the definition of the useful class in the
pickle case it was just a little bit annoying to
have that extra stuff printed out but in this case
we're doing some multi-processing the goal is to
compute the values of this useful function over
some list of inputs multiprocessing pool is going
to start up a bunch of different python processes
that all automatically import this file but
without an if name main you can see how this
starts to get into trouble just importing the
file starts up new processes which then import
the file and so on so you pretty much can't use
multi-processing in this case look what happens
and i can't even kill it with
control c i have to kill the terminal
putting this code in an if name main prevents
the rampant process spawning but again without
putting this in a separate function this is
now going to give me a global variable named p
all you have to do to avoid this headache is
just use the idiom it's not that much typing
and in fact you could probably just set up
your editor to have it there automatically
when you make a new file or just have a
template to paste it when you type main
one final less used reason
for making a main function
is that this allows you to have an entry point to
your program that you can use from other scripts
so i don't have to run this from the command line
i could import this from another file and then
call the main function as if i was running it from
the command line without starting a new process
in this case you can have your main take in
whatever arguments as an optional parameter
alright that's all i've got on the def main if
name main idiom let me know if you found any
other reasons to use it also let me know if you're
a hold out what your reasons are for not using it
as usual thanks to my patrons and
to my donors for supporting me
if you liked the video don't forget to subscribe
and hit the like button see you next time you